bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de samsung et on va essayer de voir
ensemble quels produits samsung ht en
entrée de gamme
cette vidéo fait partie d'une série de
quatre vidéos l'entrée de gamme le moyen
de gamme le haut de gamme et enfin un
bilan global pour vraiment savoir quel
smartphone samsung ht mais tout de suite
on va se recentrer sur l'entrée de gamme
et on y va maintenant
m
l'entrée de gamme chez samsung s'appelle
la gamme j alors dans la gamme geely a
beaucoup de smartphones on va essayer un
petit peu au travers de ce voyage au
travers de ses modèles savoir lequel
acheter dans quel budget lequel est
intéressant lequel n'est pas du tout
intéressant lequel il faut acheter
lequel se détachent lequel est fait pour
vous et on va regarder ça tout de suite
dans laquelle j vous n'avez pas moins de
sept smartphone alors je vous les
énumérer
bien évidemment dans cette vidéo on va
pas regarder les points techniques les
uns après les autres parce que c'est
complètement imbuvable ce qu'on va faire
a contrario c'est vraiment effectivement
de sortir l'essence même de chaque
produit pour voir lequel est intéressant
pour vous et lequel est adapté
effectivement à vos besoins pour ça je
me suis fait un comparatif a voulu
marquer ça n'a strictement aucun intérêt
mais je vais en tout cas vous présenter
les différents produits en tout cas à la
gamme gicon actuellement qui est
présenté sur le site de samsung qui est
encore présent tout de suite comporte
deux années principal la gamme de 2016
et la gamme de 2017
dans la gamme de 2016 vous avez le j1 j3
et j5 j 7 et dans la gamme de 2017 vous
avez le j3 et j5 g7 pour faire simple ce
qui va vraiment différent cessé de gamme
c'est déjà un petit peu le design dans
la gamme de 2016 vous avez un aspect
assez plastique un peu moins cali en
qualitatif en tout cas en termes
d'esthétique et sur la gamme de 2017
vous arrivez sur des produits métal qui
ont sont tout de suite beaucoup plus
esthétique
pour faire très simple bien évidemment
excusez moi je vais m'appuyer là dessus
et ça sera quand même beaucoup plus
facile déjà dans un premier temps ce qui
est intéressant ce qu'on regarde en
premier c'est l'écran alors il faut
savoir que j en 2016 un petit écran de
4,5 pouces côté résolution vous êtes au
plus bas sur le j1 en 800 pixels par 480
donc c'est vraiment un truc tout petit
c'est vraiment une petite résolution
ensuite vous arrivez à partir du j3
jusqu'au j5 de 2017 en 1280 par 720 pc
l'uhd et si vous voulez du full hd
il faut arriver sûr le j7 de 2017
laurent seigne un côté performances il
faut pas s'attendre à des trucs de
dingue
vous allez par des smartphones qui vont
être hyper puissant sens qu'elle voulait
faire tourner des applications
gourmandes
bien au contraire sont des produits
d'entrée de gamme dans quelque chose qui
vous permettre de capter quelques
souvenirs en termes de photographie
d'avoir des applications qui tournent
des applications un peu classique
c'est-à-dire de la bureautique vos
réseaux sociaux d email une utilisation
assez standard on va pas chercher à le
pousser dans ses retranchements parce
que ça ne fonctionnera pas vous
permettra pas d'utiliser des
applications gourmandes
côté stockage non plus sont pas des
foudres de guerre vous avez au maximum
16 gigaoctets de stockage dont 10 gigas
disponible donc sur ses smartphones là
je vous conseille vraiment dû prendre
une carte mémoire en plus pourrait
rajouter de la mémoire dans la gamme de
2016 vous pouvez rajouter jusqu'à 128
giga et dans la garde et dans la gamme
de 2017
vous pouvez rajouter jusqu'à 256 giguère
petite particularité sur le gie celle de
2017 la possibilité de mettre une double
carte sim
ça peut être intéressant si
effectivement vous partez à l'étranger
vous a besoin de rajouter une carte sim
deuxième carte sim votre carte française
ou la carte de votre pays et ensuite la
carte du pays étrangers ça peut être
intéressant c'est le seul qui le propose
dans cette gamme lente aucun à noter
également que il ya uniquement le j5 et
le j 7 de 2017 qui vous permettent
d'avoir le lecteur d'empreintes
digitales pour déverrouiller votre
smartphone
pour les autres il faut faire uniquement
le schéma ou un code je vous donnais à
peu près les budgets moyens ses
smartphones sur le lien vous allez
trouver à 130 le j3 à 149 euros
le gie 580 euros le j7 de 2016 tous à 1
250 euros
le j3 de 2010 799 euros le j5 de 2017
259 euros et le gie 07/02/2010 7 309
euros donc vraiment qu'on a une
évolution des prix du plus petit et
moins de 100 euros aux smartphones à un
peu plus de 300 euros
alors dans l'ensemble quel est le
smartphone quels sont les smartphones en
tout cas qui ont un vrai intérêt dans la
gamme de 2016 n'est pas beaucoup de
produits qui retient mon attention
le j en ai effectivement pas cher du
tout en dessous des 200 euros
par contre côté performances c'est
vraiment pas ça du tout mais si vous
cherchez un smartphone samsung vraiment
pas cher pourquoi pas mais bon vous
risquez d'être déçu une résolution 800
par 480 pixels
même si c'est un écran super amoled
sépare fantastique du tout le j3 2016
pareil pour moi c'est un modèle à
oublier le j5 de 2016 par contre je
trouve plutôt pas mal c'est un
smartphone qui coûtent moins de 200
euros et qui franchement affiche des
caractéristiques qui sont assez sexy a
contrario je trouve que le j 7 de 2016
et cher pour les caractéristiques
techniques pour moi dans la gamme en
tout cas de 2
celle je retiendrai le j5 c'est un écran
super amoled est une révolution en 1280
par 720 p donc c'est du hd mais bon
voilà je vous donne pas plus on est dans
l'entrée de gamme ça fonctionne il est
un capteur photo principale de 13 mio
pixels avec une ouverture de 1.9 ça
c'est plutôt pas mal pour avoir des
photos je dirais en faible luminosité
alors on va pas chercher vraiment être
dans le noir mais dès que la lumière va
baisser un petit peu je vous permettra
effectivement de capter quelque chose de
plutôt pas mal la caméra de celle fils
et une 5 mégapixels une fois de plus on
est en train de mener sur l'entrée de
gamme donc on va pas chercher un truc de
dingue
vous pouvez faire des vidéos en full hd
en 1920 par 1080 en 30 images par
secondes ça fonctionne parfaitement bien
la batterie c'est une 3100 millions
perreur ça fonctionne
côté processeur safra la sphère
largement pour ce dont vous avez besoin
sur cette typologie de produits
on a deux gigas de ram 16 go de stockage
il faut la monter jusqu'à au moins 64
giga 6 928 au maximum parce que de toute
façon vous allez tout de suite hyper
embêté bon après l'échec du bluetooth
2.1 un port jack la connectique c'est du
microusb bombe à rien rien de
révolutionnaire là dessus mais pour le
prix à 180 euros
je trouve qu'il fait vraiment la faire
ensuite dans la gamme de 2017 pour moi
il ya un produit a directement oublier
c'est le j3 je trouve qu'il ya des
performances qui sont vraiment en deçà
est pas génial en plus de ça au lieu
d'avoir un écran super amoled vous avez
un écran lcd
tous les autres sont du super amoled et
la femme il vaut col du lcd alors le j3
on le prend en jette
on va plutôt s'intéresser à mon avis au
j 5 le gie set je le trouve pas génial
logis sept îles et bien si vous voulez
effectivement la double carte sim
sinon il a assez peu d'intérêt parce
qu'il passe quand même les 300 euros
je trouve a contrario plus j5 de 2017
est vraiment pas mal du tout vous avez
un écran 5,2 pouces hd 1280 par 720
pixels une caméra principale de 13
mégapixels avec une ouverture de f 1.7
ça c'est plutôt pas mal pour les photos
en faible luminosité
côté scène fillon mais aussi une 13
mégapixels avec une ouverture un petit
peu plus haute qui va capter un peu
moins les lumières en faible luminosité
mais l'ouverture locale plutôt pas mal
c'est une ouverture de f 1.9 il est tout
en métal il est assez séduisant je
trouve plutôt bien réussi d'ailleurs
mieux réussi que le modèle j5 de 2016
une batterie 3 millions terreur qui fera
vraiment la faire d'ailleurs il faut
savoir que sur le s9 vous avez également
une batterie promet une vie antérieure
donc là vous inquiétez pas ça fera
parfaitement la faire à la différence de
tous les autres modèles d'avant il ya le
capteur d'empreintes digitales comme
jeudi
et il ya pas mal de choses qui sont
assez sexy et surtout y coûte 259 euros
ça c'est très bien à mon avis c'est le
meilleur s'il ya un seul produit à
retenir dans l'entrée de gamme chez
samsung
c'est le j5 de 2017 pour moi c'est
vraiment un produit qui est très bien
parce qu'il reprend il est très très
proche du g7 qui coûte quand même un peu
plus de 300 euros
alors effectivement le g7 un écran un
peu plus grand de 5,5 pouces avec une
résolution full hd 1920 par 1080 mais
bon lorsque vous êtes dans l'entrée de
gamme
vous vous en fichez un petit peu c'est
pas vraiment ce qu'on va aller
rechercher là dessus et je trouve que le
rapport qualité prix du j5 2017 est
vraiment bien alors bilan dans cette
entrée de gamme
qu'est-ce qu'on va choisir entre les
modèles de 2016 les modèles de 2017 d'un
côté quatre modèles de 2005 d'un côté
trois modèles de 2010 est pour moi il ya
deux modèles qui se détache et si je
devais en retenir qu'un seul ça serait
le j5 de 2017
et comme je vous le disais il un super
rapport qualité prix le j5 de 2016 est
plutôt pas mal si vous avez un budget en
dessous des 200 euros à 180 euros de
moyenne
c'est vraiment un produit qui
fonctionnera bien et vous serez pas
déçus si par contre vous pouvez rajouter
un petit peu plus vous arrivez à 259
euros et là vous avez un produit qui est
vraiment très bien avec une caméra qui
permettra de faire de bonnes photos et
bonnes vidéos vos vidéos fossard vous
filmez quand même en full hd en 1920 par
1080 à 30 images par seconde donc c'est
vraiment bien ces standards d'ailleurs
moi c'est ce que je fais sont mes images
là sur les vidéos que je diffuse sur
youtube c'est du 1920 par 1080 c'est du
full hd en 25 images par seconde donc
voyez vous êtes vraiment dans les
standards en terme de vidéo en termes de
photos ça fonctionne bien quelque chose
d'assez lumineux donc dès que la lumière
va baisser
vous aurez des photos de qualité côté
stockage c'est un peu light mais il
faudra des forcément une carte microsd
là ça sera parfaitement bien à faire
vous êtes un écran super amoled 5,2
pouce pour moi y'a rien à dire même si
on est sur une résolution hd en 1280 par
720 p bon ça fonctionne une fois de plus
on est sur un produit d'entrée de gamme
on va pas lui demander la lune
si vous voulez des produits qui sont
plus performants on va aller sur la
gamme à ou sur la gamme s d'ailleurs je
vous invite à voir dans l'inscription je
vous rajoute au fur et à mesure les
liens des autres vidéos et vous allez
voir ce côté là il y aussi des produits
qui sont super intéressant par contre il
faut augmenter légèrement le budget
voilà un peu ce que je pouvais vous dire
sur ces produits
d'entrée de gamme de chez samsung dans
la gamme j s'il vous intéresse je vous
ai mis des liens vers description je
vous invite à passer par ces liens pour
les acheter tout simplement pas pour
m'enrichir mais pour soutenir mon
travail et me permettre de faire
toujours plus d'un contenu merci à vous
je vous invite bien évidemment à voir
les autres vidéos parce que comme je
vous le dis il ya la gabegie à la gamme
mac et milieu de gamme via la gamme s
qui est le haut de gamme et à la gamme s
je vais coller la gamme note parce que
dans un cas de notes
il n'y a plus beaucoup de produits donc
voilà rester connecté on regarde tout ça
ensemble je remercie beaucoup d'avoir
regardé cette vidéo peut les mettre tous
vos retours d'expérience est ce que vous
avez eu des produits de la gamme j la
gamme à de la gamme s la gaine note
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
on partage tout ça on se renseigne les
uns les autres c'est convivial c'est
sympa voilà merci à vous et à très
bientôt pour parler de la gamma de la
gamme est de la gamme note
je vous embrasse ciao ciao